[Musica]
sapete cosa vuol dire andare
controcorrente
significa che per ogni passo che
facciamo troviamo una forza contraria
che dobbiamo vincere ed è difficile ci
vogliono muscoli e ci vuole fegato e
sarebbe di sicuro più facile lasciarsi
trasportare Quindi se vi chiedete chi me
lo fa fare avete ragione però lasciate
che io comunque provi a darvi una sorta
di risposta e vediamo se vi convinco
ma prima Sappiate che se nella vita
sentite di andare controcorrente Siete
dei salmoni Sì dei salmoni e giuro che
non è tipo un insulto I salmoni sono dei
pesci che nascono in mare e poi
risalgono i fiumi
alla fine possiamo pensarla così siamo
tutti
nati in mare un mare con dentro un po'
di tutto
Apriamo gli occhi e ci ritroviamo
sballottolati qua e là dalla corrente e
non c'è molto da fare perché da bambini
Siamo fragili
siamo deboli e siamo creduloni
soprattutto e ci va di pensare che
quello che abbiamo è proprio proprio
preciso quello che vogliamo e che
abbiamo sempre voluto e che vogliamo per
il nostro futuro perché è più semplice
siamo più delle alici appena nate che
dei salmoni
voglio dire non è che ci sia qualcosa di
peccaminosamente sbagliato nel lasciarsi
trasportare si tratta più di quello che
vogliamo fare per noi stessi quindi
colpe non ce ne sono
al massimo ce la possiamo prendere con
noi stessi
però non la metterei proprio nel libro
delle cose intelligenti da fare
nemmeno l'opinione degli altri a colpo
però è un elemento che ha un peso è
quella vocina che ci si insinua nella
testa
e inizia a darci fastidio arrangiarci
arrangiarsi nelle orecchie e diventa il
pensiero comune il pensiero comune che
poi vabbè alla fine va lasciata a se
stessa quella vocina Perché non è una
verità assoluta è quello che pensa alla
gente la gente che vuole che gli altri
la pensano allo stesso modo
Beh facciamo che adesso vi parlo un po'
di me
Io sono Greta
Greta è una ragazza tranquilla
sorridente gentile
Greta è questo Beh se mi si conosce da
fuori
in realtà penso capiate anche voi che
sia bene o male impossibile essere
sempre così ciò che mi frega è una
terribile tremenda paura dei litigi
di chi urla e di chi sbatte le porte
non riesco a sostenere il caos che c'è
nel mondo perché per me i litigi sono
sempre stati Il modo che avevano le
persone per ferire gli altri
E ho scoperto solo da poco che se si
litiga per un motivo che noi riteniamo
giusto
li possiamo accettare quei litigi e li
dobbiamo fare
non devono diventare guerre però
Dobbiamo capire
che hanno una sorta di importanza anche
loro perché anche se ci sono un po' di
esplosioni si tratta sempre di due
correnti che si scontrano in mare quindi
proprio calmo il mare non può rimanere
quindi Beh ho passato gran parte della
mia vita a fingermi calma a evitare ogni
tipo di discussione e a spegnere le
micce che magari nemmeno accendevo io e
magari avrei dovuto farmi un po' i fatti
miei
e ho sbagliato
ho sbagliato perché ho preso il
sopravvivere come un modo più figo di
dire vivere ma il sopravvivere è un
qualcosa di temporaneo
volto a salvare un momento e poi il
momento dopo e assicurarsi in ogni
istante che ce ne sia un altro
ma ci dimentichiamo della qualità di
quei momenti
c'è un mondo Proprio là fuori
davvero pieno e se stiamo attenti per
qualche momento possiamo riuscire ad
intravedere un po' della meraviglia che
contiene la creiamo proprio noi ne siamo
capaci ce l'abbiamo nel sangue
soprattutto noi giovani che a dir la
verità sappiamo proprio essere dei pezzi
d'arte
innovativi intelligenti sorprendenti
Però tutto quel colore quella meraviglia
che ci scorre nel sangue arriva alla
verità delle cose
ci sono gli ostacoli
c'è la zia Nina che parla con la zia
Franca e ci guardano un po' male e poi
c'è il vicino di casa che di ritorno
dalla sua acquisto del giornale ci
squadra da capo a piedi e beh c'è la
signora Giovanna che al piano di sopra
mentre stende i panni borbotta e non per
non farsi sentire e tutti loro iniziano
a fare un grande rumore
e Iniziamo a pensare che nella nostra
vita l'unica cosa che dobbiamo fare è
far smettere quel rumore
Ma così torniamo a quel maledettissimo
concetto del sopravvivere Quindi questa
strada dobbiamo cercare di evitarla
Allora che facciamo magari potremmo
mettere le cuffiette ma vedremo gli
sguardi potremmo chiudere gli occhi ma
sentiremo le spinte allora
Beh allora ce ne possiamo andare
Beh vi ho detto come mi chiamo vi ho
confessato una mia terribile paura
quindi direi che siamo in confidenza
posso quindi raccontarvi un'altra parte
della storia
sono nata a Roma e Secondo me
dall'accento qualcuno l'aveva capito
Comunque sì sono nata e cresciuta lì
fino alla veneranda età di 14 anni dico
Veneranda perché ne ho 16 quindi 14 è un
bel numero Infatti ho costruito lì tutto
amici Scuola luoghi
Roma è una città molto grande e può
farti sentire sola
so che sembra una frase fatta sentita e
risentita però a volte è vero
comunque
sono andata a Roma e poi mi sono
trasferita qui
da piccolo non pensavo che me ne sarei
mai andata che avrei cambiato anche un
singolo granello di tutto quello che
sarebbe stata la mia vita o che era in
quel momento però c'erano diverse cose
che non mi andavano bene
ricordo che nel mio giardino c'era un
amaca di quelle bianche in corda
scomodissime e io ci stavo ore
a fantasticare su tutto quello che avrei
cambiato nella mia vita Un attimo dopo
essere diventata adulta
Beh non è proprio così che funziona
l'ho capito solo dopo diventerà adulti
non è tipo passi in un portale Boom sei
adulto È un processo in cui Bisogna
raccogliere il coraggio di cambiare
e di scegliere per se stessi perché alla
fine si tratta di questo
si tratta di quanto Vogliamo darci una
mano e quanto invece vogliamo legarci
insieme ai lacci delle scarpe
col tempo però quella sensazione di
solitudine che tra parentesi non era
data dalla città non diamo colpa a Roma
che non ha
cresceva E diventava difficile ignorarla
Allora Beh mi sono iniziata a guardare
attorno e ho notato che mio padre era un
salmone Papà sei un salmone
sei cresciuto nel mare di Roma per circa
30 anni poi la vita ti ha portato qui
ora Non voglio rendere le cose così
semplici e lineari
però a volte la vita ci dà delle
possibilità che dobbiamo essere bravi a
cogliere
Beh questo mi ha fatto riflettere mi ha
reso carica energica e ho iniziato a
mettere sul piatto della Bilancia quello
che perdevo e quello che acquistava
andandomene e dopo aver constatato che
andandomene lasciavo tutti i miei amici
metà della mia famiglia il mio cane e la
mia gelateria preferita Beh ho preso un
po' di roba l'ho messa in degli
scatoloni ho scelto un liceo dove
trasferirmi e me ne sono andata
a volte ci perdiamo nei dettagli e non
riusciamo a vedere
il nocciolo della questione perché quel
gelato era delizioso ancora me lo sogno
la notte ma io lo mangiavo con l'amaro
in bocca Quindi non aveva poi tutto
questo senso
siamo tutti nati in un paese in un
quartiere in una città E vi assicuro che
il mondo continua a funzionare così
e se ci dice bene
perché no ci ritroviamo in un posto che
è il nostro ci stiamo bene insomma
Ma se non è così abbiamo l'imperativo di
andarcene
c'è un dovere che non ci viene insegnato
a scuola o almeno non abbastanza
ed è quello verso noi stessi Per farla
breve non troppo filosofica non
trattiamoci troppo male Non
sacrifichiamoci per qualche bene
superiore o qualche missione Divina
perché so che può sembrare ancora più
banale ma stare bene non è un qualcosa
di egoistico
per niente
quindi prendetelo come un regalo che
fate a voi stessi al futuro
vostro e di tutti quelli che vi stanno
attorno
siamo fatti in realtà di tutto quello
che incontriamo le persone le parole e i
gesti quindi scegliere in qualche modo
quello che incontriamo
è un compito che tocca a noi
forse è l'ora di rimescolare un po' le
carte possiamo cambiare le cose possiamo
scegliere noi dove andare cosa fare
possiamo decidere di prendere la vita di
petto magari proprio correre incontro e
poi
e poi c'è quella questione che rimane un
po' in sospeso
che ci rimane nella testa quella
degli altri che pensano
gli altri
sembrano entità eppure sono sempre
persone opinioni come noi ma sanno come
darci veramente fastidio
Infatti sapete la storia che vi
raccontavo prima su Roma Beh non è
finita perché sì ho deciso di andarmene
ma tra questo è il farlo C'è stato un
passaggio di mezzo perché ho dovuto
dirlo comunicarlo
In effetti andarmene senza dire niente
Poteva sembrare un po' troppo drammatico
anche per me Perciò
l'ho comunicato e nel momento nel
momento stesso in cui l'ho fatto sono
iniziate a raffica delle domande
intelligentissime del tipo Cioè tu te ne
vai da Roma e ti trasferisci al sud E
peraltro Vai a vivere con tuo padre Cioè
ma sei seria Vabbè ma poi torni no
praticamente Segui i salmoni cioè Risali
i fiumi ma chi te lo fa fare chi te
cieca mi dire mi dicevano a Roma no E
poi Beh sono venuta qua e più o meno mi
fanno la stessa domanda
mi dicono Ma che vita ha fatto fa in
calabrese ora Perdonate la pronuncia
Però più o meno l'avete capito il
concetto Il fatto è che io non ho fatto
una fuga da dove Capito Capito E vediamo
se mi dice bene
io qui ci sto bene davvero
spesso mi chiedono Ma come ti trovi E io
rispondo che si sta meglio di Roma e non
mi crede nessuno Io cerco di dirlo con
la massima serietà possibile
Sapete qual è la cosa curiosa
Io mi sono trasferita dalla città dei
sette colli e della lupa
Poi cambio città cambio parte
dell'Italia cambio regione e dove mi
ritrovo nella città dei sette colli e
dei lupi
Questo per dire che
solo per dirvi che alla fine le cose
ritrovano un proprio posto e non parlo
di Universo parlo del fatto che io ho
trovato il mio posto
Beh controcorrente Eravamo partiti così
la prima volta che ho sentito questa
parola mi si è fissata in mente
un'immagine
Infatti Durante le festività a volte
torno a Roma e
la stragrande maggioranza delle persone
invece da Roma se le torna nelle proprie
città
e sull'autostrada non c'è nessuno cioè
si viaggia che è una meraviglia
veramente tipo 160 e via ma dall'altra
parte invece le macchine clacson l'altra
corsia è piena e io beh ne apprezzo
l'ironia
andiamo controcorrente
lo so suona come una cosa grossa e lo è
è una responsabilità
perché è una scommessa che facciamo sul
futuro e la dobbiamo fare perché il
nostro futuro Quindi Beh mettiamo su un
po' di muscoli raccogliamo il fegato che
serve e facciamo i salmoni della
situazione che alla fine le acque dei
fiumi sono anche più pulite
Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]